Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
Ciudad de México el día de muertos es
una de las más importantes celebraciones
para los mexicanos declarada por la
UNESCO como patrimonio cultural
inmaterial de la humanidad en esta
ocasión visitaremos Zapotitlán un pueblo
originario en la alcaldía Tláhuac al sur
de la capital del país un grupo de
artistas nos compartirá el proceso de
creación de las calaveras y catrinas
monumentales conoceremos la forma de
elaborar el tradicional pan de muerto y
visitaremos un campo de cultivo de flor
de cempasúchil típica de esta
conmemoración milenaria acompáñenos
para la civilizaciones prehispánicas
Cuando alguien moría emprendía un viaje
a un lugar mítico llamado mictlán desde
ese Inframundo una vez cada año Las
ánimas volvían para reunirse con sus
seres queridos aún vivos lo cual era
motivo de júbilo y festejo para ello
familiares y amigos preparaban una
ofrenda con los alimentos y bebidas
califunto le gustaban en vida con la
creencia de que en su retorno momentáneo
disfrutarían El banquete con la
imposición de la religión católica este
rasgo cultural no desapareció sino que
se armonizó con el día de todos los
santos así cada dos de noviembre en todo
el país se celebra el Día de Muertos
para propiciar un encuentro simbólico
con el espíritu de los seres queridos En
un ambiente festivo y de alegría En su
memoria el arte ha estado siempre muy
presente en el Día de Muertos en
Zapotitlán en el taller del grupo
cultural tradición y tiempo de Filiberto
Valdez elaboran figuras volumétricas
alusivas a la muerte como calaveras y
catrinas que adornan las escenas de las
composiciones también manufacturan los
elementos decorativos para las maquetas
de Día de Muertos primero hay que tener
el diseño de qué es lo que queremos
hacer Si una persona parada una persona
a caballo una persona sentada y de esta
manera se va trabajando poco a poco todo
el proceso de cartonería este este
proceso de cartonería Ya estando la
pieza que nosotros queremos pasa otro
proceso que es el de pintado y decorado
en Santiago Zapotitlán hay varios grupos
que se dedican a elaborar escenas en
cartonería o composiciones creaciones de
vida también se le puede llamar a través
de calaveras para este exponerlas los
días 30 31 de octubre y principalmente
primero y 2 de noviembre 2 de noviembre
donde la comunidad sale a las calles a
visitar ofrendas y a visitar todas estas
creaciones el concepto de la Catrina
tiene sus orígenes en la calavera
garbancera creada poli caricaturista
mexicano José Guadalupe posada a finales
del siglo XX como una crítica social a
los indígenas adinerados que
menospreciaban sus raíces
más tarde el importante muralista Diego
Rivera La retomó en sus pinturas y la
bautizó como la catrina como sátira de
una sociedad acomodada desde entonces ha
estado ligada a la celebración de Día de
Muertos y forma parte de la atmósfera
decorativa
llevo más de 50 años elaborando catrinas
cada vez con más este creatividad más
este colorido La Catrina ahora viene
hecha en hoja de maíz en hoja de Tule de
diferentes materiales pero la cantidad
está ahí o sea eso es lo que lo que ha
manifestado O sea la Catrina ha sido
como un motor de diferentes este
actitudes de la sociedad y que es parte
de de una representación mexicana
parte del colorido que envuelve la
celebración del Día de Muertos proviene
de la flor de Cempasúchil la leyenda
cuenta que su peculiar aroma Guía a los
difuntos hasta las ofrendas que se
montan en su honor no hay altar de
muertos sin flor de cempasúchil Y aunque
hoy en día china e India son los
principales productores globales el
Cempasúchil es una flor nativa de México
por eso cuando
desde el día 26 de octubre mucha gente
utiliza el pétalo compran y lo ponen
como caminito en las casas para qué
parque guían a las Ánimas siempre
por eso nosotros
seguimos con esa tradición de que es el
Cempasúchil si bien las calaveritas de
azúcar o de chocolate no pueden faltar
en el marco de esta celebraciones sin
duda el pan de muerto es una de Las
Delicias de la época más esperadas por
los mexicanos
hoy en día hay cualquier cantidad de
variantes de pan de muerto con nuez con
chispas de chocolate con relleno de nata
y empanaderías comerciales y tiendas de
autoservicio se puede encontrar desde
principios de septiembre pero el que
elaboran los panaderos de Zapotitlán es
único por su fidelidad a los orígenes el
pan de muerto aquí en la ofrenda
representa la iglesia el símbolo de la
de la tumba el olor que se llevan los
difuntos aquí nos decían o las historias
que nos contaban nuestros antepasados
era que los difunditos vienen y se
llevan el olor se llevan el sabor y pues
la verdad pues si es real más que
competir con otras expresiones como la
noche de brujas o el Halloween la
festividad de Día de Muertos se debate
entre el apego a los orígenes y una
visión moderna muy turística y hasta
comercial de esta importante
manifestación cultural
exposiciones como mexicanos que suelta a
la creatividad de los diseños de cientos
de artistas o el ya famoso desfile de
Día de Muertos por la avenida Paseo de
la Reforma son muestras de sincretismo y
dan cuenta de una tradición cada vez más
Viva en la población mexicana
Gracias por acompañarnos en el enlace
Norteamérica desde Ciudad de México soy
Mario carbonell y en la cámara mi
compañera Lizeth Romero Hasta pronto